ARTUR TILIERI: Hi.
Nice to meet you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Artur.
I work for Cartoon Network.
I'm the regional
senior digital manager.
That's a fancy thing
to say, but I basically
work on the content
team at Cartoon Network,
basically creating
content for digital.
I'm a gamer.
I'm a designer.
I graduated in design.
I'm a YouTuber as well.
My channel has an
impressive number
of 12 followers, 12 subscribers.
So that's fancy for me.
And just to talk a
little bit of what we do
and what is Cartoon Network.
So this is Cartoon Network.
We are not a TV channel.
We are a strong brand.
And we are working with a
lot of different platforms.
We have the TV channel.
The TV channel has been
existing for more than 20 years.
So this is the number
one thing that we do.
We are number one in
ratings with kids.
And this is important for us.
We do work a lot with
site, games, applications,
digital, social media.
So this is huge for us.
This has been huge for
more than 15 years.
The Cartoon Network's website,
when I was a kid, like 25,
30 years ago, I used to enter--
not 30, maybe a little bit
less-- but I used to enter on
the Cartoon Network website
and I used to play games.
We started building
games from-- at least,
when I was growing up,
I was playing, already,
the Cartoon Network games.
So this was really important
for us from the beginning.
And we do have, also,
a strong licensing
and live events and stuff
that we do on Cartoon Network
as well.
So this is a little bit of
who we are and what we do.
So I'm going to talk about some
of the learnings of building
apps and games from the
past five or six years.
So this is something
of what we came across
and some of the stuff that
we realized was important.
And I wanted to point out
in a top 10 list of things
that we learned by developing
our games and our apps
and we learned from
our audience and we
learned from our fan base.
And this is the
most important thing
that you need to understand--
whenever you are talking
about user acquisition or user
engagement, the first thing
that you need to do is actually
listening to your audience
and understanding what they are
asking and how they are asking.
So first of all, I cannot
express the importance
of your content.
I mean, content is the number
one thing you have to look at.
Whenever you're developing
an idea, creating an idea,
developing a game,
you should consider
your content and how you're
working with the content.
I mean, the gameplay is key.
I mean, if you're
developing a game,
please take a look
at the gameplay.
How does it work?
How do kids play
with the gameplay?
This is really important.
And this actually will show
up in the later stage--
if you don't prepare
your gameplay
to be fun in the beginning, in
the end stage it won't work.
So this is, specifically,
to Cartoon, I mean, our IPs,
they are everywhere.
They are on games.
They are on TV.
They are on licensing.
They are on live events.
So this is how we do.
We tend to work on a bigger
storytelling approach.
So what happened with
this is that gaming
is a part of that IP, of
that intellectual property.
So we try to expand the
storytelling approach.
So you will learn some
key things from the game.
Playing the game and
watching the series,
you will learn some new things.
And this is something
that actually
changed within Cartoon Network.
Usually, digital was
separated from content.
So the studios in LA that
develop all of our shows,
they were separated
from digital.
So what happened is that
we simply merged together.
So right now, digital
is part of content
and digital is seen as content.
So we work closely
together with the studios
to actually create and develop
games and create ideas.
And the storytelling
is a big part of this.
So a lot of our
games are actually
being worked by the same script
writers that work with the TV
shows.
So in this way,
you assure that you
are working on something that
makes sense for the audience
and it connects
with your brand ID.
So this is really important.
Again, content is
also understanding
what your kids like.
So look at the kids.
Look at what they
watch, what they play.
Understand what they consume
so you can apply and learn
from that whenever you're
producing any of your apps
and whenever you're
working with content.
So if you're working on a
title that has too much text,
maybe that's not something
that a younger kid would like.
Maybe you need to understand
how they're consuming that
before planning
that into your game
so you're not
caught in surprise.
We don't want to
have a huge story
because we know that the
gameplay is more important.
So this is also important
to evaluate whenever
you're creating your games.
So please always check
on what kids are doing.
So this is an example
that I like to point out.
This is "Steven
Attack the Light."
This is actually an app
that was released in 2015.
This was an app-- it is
one of our greatest apps.
We worked with the show
crew to develop the app.
Not only the story was
created by the show
team, the same script writers,
but the full aspect of the app
was developed by our team
from the studios in LA.
So what we were
doing was like, OK,
let's take a look to be sure
that this app and this game
communicates to what
"Steven" truly is.
And whenever this
happens, it's really
fun to just go through
the comments on the store
and just realize that people
are really commenting like, hey,
this app feels like an
episode of the show.
And this is amazing for us.
And this is part of
working together.
And this is the
results that we have.
So this is something that it's
really important content-wise.
The second thing
that I would say
that it's really
important-- and sometimes I
feel like in the past
maybe we forgot sometimes--
but you're working with kids,
so you need to think as a parent
and think as a kid
at the same time.
So you cannot propose an
app that has something that
a parent might not like.
So for instance,
at one point, we
were really, oh, it
would be nice to have
more social appeal.
Let's place Facebook,
like a Facebook plug-in
so people can share
the app on Facebook.
But when you start
to think on that,
it's really delicate
the way that you
need to work with your content
so you're not pushing kids
to someplace that they
are not supposed to be
or pushing kids to
a place that parents
wouldn't like the kids to be.
Sometimes the kids
are out there.
We see some research and kids
are saying, oh, I'm there.
My parent doesn't know.
I'm accessing Facebook.
I have an account.
But what happens is that they
are going against their parents
and we need to think
with the parents' head.
I mean, if the parent
doesn't like it,
we shouldn't do it as well.
So we need to come up
with a good balance
and understand what we can
do and what we can offer,
so we are not
delivering something
that's not harmful for either
the kid or the parents.
And that's why this
is a strong point
because I think sometimes we
completely forget about this.
I mean, we're working with
kids, so how should you place
your in-app purchase content?
I mean, again, you're
working with kids,
so sometimes we receive
some news like a kid spends,
I don't know, $5,000 on an app.
So that's not really good.
So you have to really balance
and, again, think as a parent,
think as a kid, and see
how you are demonstrating
that inside your game.
So I can go on.
I mean, there's
like-- for instance,
if you're launching
your game on US,
you have COPPA,
which is legal that
has some restrictions with kids
and how you collect information
from kids.
So this is really
sensitive information
that you need to
consider whenever you're
producing an app for a kid.
So number three-- I mean,
how does your game stand out?
I mean, looking
at the app store,
looking at all the games,
looking with the games
that are trending up, how
you are separating your games
from what is already launched.
We, in Cartoon, we never
simply, OK, "Flappy Birds"
is doing amazing.
Let's just create
a "Flappy Birds"
with a cartoon character.
That's not how we play it.
That's not how we
sell our games.
And that's not how we
envision the creation
of content and gaming.
So what we usually
do is actually
thinking a little bit more.
So "Flappy Birds" is
something that works,
how can we learn from that?
What are the things that
kids are addicted to?
How can we evolve that and add
a new thing inside of our game?
So how can we
innovate on something
that was already launched?
So this is number
three because it's
part of the Cartoon Network
DNA, which is innovation.
I mean, if we take a little
bit from the previous talk--
I mean, we were learning
about kids curiosity.
So this is important
for us as well,
which is actually bringing
some new stuff so the kids can
actually have something new
to iterate and to learn from.
So it's not simply a
copy from another game.
So this is another thing
that is really important.
And what we learned
a lot from this
is that iteration-- I mean,
once you have a game project,
from day one to, I don't
know, day five, day ten,
day one hundred, the
game keeps on changing.
I mean, you learn a
lot from play testing.
So you play test with
a kid and you'll simply
understand it's
something that you
imagine like, oh, this is just
like a side part of the app.
Suddenly, that's
the thing that you
need to focus your
efforts on because this
is the thing that
it's playing the most
and kids are enjoying the most.
So your game constantly changes.
And the project will
never be the same
because it keeps on evolving.
And it keeps on
evolving and changing.
So this is an example
that we do as well.
This is "Adventure
Time: Game Wizard."
This is a game that we released
in 2013, if I'm not mistaken.
And this involved
innovation in so many ways.
I mean, it was like a
platform, I think, on Mario,
but the big change to this
game is that you could actually
create your own game on paper.
So you could draw your levels
and you could scan your levels
through a cell phone.
And that level would
be read by the app
and you could play the
game on your own level.
And kids could create a
vast majority of levels.
You could play with other
levels created by other kids.
And the way that you
created the level, as well,
was like really simple.
You didn't have to draw a lot,
but the app understood signals.
So if you designed a plus
sign on a sheet of paper,
it would understand,
this plus sign is a coin.
So it would read that and it
would throw that in the app.
So for us, this is something
that was really cool because it
was actually uniting something.
Again, when I was a
kid, I used to love
to do that, which was
basically drawing.
And we are trying
to unite something
that kids like to do live
and something that they
like to do on digital.
So this was something that
was really important for us.
And it had a huge
UGC opportunity.
So for us, this was
really cool as well
because you could share
what we were doing.
It's not a social media,
but inside the app
you could actually see that
other people were playing.
You could like other
people's levels.
So this was good as well.
Kids love to play
and like stuff.
So this, for us,
enabled other things
that were really
positive for us as well.
Number four, localization.
Localization, working
with kids, it's a must.
I mean, we learned
this the hard way.
Sometimes we do develop all of
the apps generated by Cartoon.
They are worked globally.
So we release an app
in every single region,
like LATAM, we work in the US,
EMEA, which is Europe and Asia.
So for us, what
we understand from
this is that whenever
we were like, OK,
let's try to launch
this game in English.
It's a simple game, maybe
it won't damage a lot.
But what do we learned from
this, whenever we launched
a game in English, it might
be really little text,
but that little text makes a
difference and people would
complain, like, hey, this
game is not in my language.
This game is not in Portuguese.
This game is not in Chinese.
This game is not in Japanese.
So for us,
localization is really
important because kids like
that and the parents like that.
And not only-- if you
think on even going back
like on TV trends,
you might hear
in Brazil-- this is really
common-- so you might think
like, most of the movie
channels, at one point,
they were all simply
dubbing all their movies.
So this is a trend,
not only for kids,
this is a trend
for adults as well.
Everyone likes to
read and they feel
comfortable to hear in
their original language.
So this is a trend.
And whenever people
ask me like, oh, no,
but how come the TV channel
changed from English subtitles
to Portuguese?
This is crazy.
I love English.
But whenever you
look at the ratings,
the ratings actually
improved after we did that.
And the same applies to apps.
And the same applies
to everything
that we do in digital.
So whenever we work
with the local language,
we get much more better results.
So this is an important
thing to understand.
And right now this is a
huge gaming market trend.
I mean, whenever you
see any game right now,
they are being translated.
If you think on the big titles,
on the PlayStation Store,
for instance, they are being
translated to Portuguese.
They have Portuguese voiceover.
So this is really
important for us.
So an example was "Card Wars."
"Card Wars" was a huge app.
I mean, it's one of
our biggest apps.
So it had a lot of text.
I mean, it was massive text.
I mean, think on a card game
with more than, I don't know,
a thousand cards.
So at one point, we
released a single patch
with new cards that
didn't have all
the translations on the cards.
And on the comments, everyone
was like, what happened?
The app is bugged.
It's showing me English text.
So we went back and we saw
that some cards were English
and we translated it.
And that made a difference.
People were like, oh,
now they heard us.
Now, it's in Portuguese.
Now, it's OK.
So this is something that's
really, really important
to understand.
And yes, it does
make a difference.
So you have to understand
the game lifecycle as well.
It's not like, OK, they
want to launch the app.
OK, I'm done.
I already released it.
Ah, I can just rest and
move on to the next thing
I'm going to do.
That's not how we see our apps.
I mean, we see our apps
as constantly evolving.
So what happens on day
one, that's day one.
I mean, you had all the
development of the app,
but day one is day one for
the lifecycle of the app.
So you need to look at the app
and you need to evolve the app.
So I see, like, in
30 days, the comments
are that this thing is broken.
OK, let's fix it.
Oh, people are saying
the game is too short.
OK, let's change it
and add new levels.
So you have to understand
that this is important.
And this will help
push your app up.
So you cannot miss this.
What we do as well, and
what is really important,
is also adding relevant
content from different seasons.
So let's say, right
now, it's Halloween.
OK, let's produce a special
package for Halloween
with special Halloween content
so kids can have something
that they relate that is
happening with their life
at the same time.
So Halloween is
a topic for them.
I'm sure that if
we have Halloween
costumes inside an app, a
kid would love to see that
and to have that.
So this is really
important for us.
And you can think on any
different-- like in Brazil,
you can think like, OK, Carnival
is something really important,
OK, maybe we should
do and we could
do a development
of, I don't know,
some Carnival themed
stuff for your app.
And that will show
the difference.
And that will be
pushed up again.
So that's really important.
The app icon, this is something
that we always talk-- I mean,
like this morning,
people were talking
about the importance
of the app icon
and testing it, and
understanding it,
and looking at our
audience, and changing it.
And that goes to iteration.
And learn from what
you're getting.
And also the app icon-- so if
you're having Halloween, maybe
you can change your app
icon, show a pumpkin
or something that has to do
with Halloween so the kids can
understand, OK,
this is Halloween.
I'm living Halloween,
so this is cool for me.
So here is another
example, "Teeny Titans."
It's a game that goes really
into the Cartoon Network DNA.
It makes a lot of fun
of these kind of games
that are like Disney
Infinity, like live toys.
And this is a game that's,
mix that with Pokemon.
And we are just making
huge fun out of this.
So what we did with
this app is actually
you had a lot of different
figurines to collect.
And this is one of our apps that
is still training right now.
We launched for
more than six months
and it's still performing
really good for us.
And on Halloween,
for instance, we
released new collectibles
that had to do with Halloween.
The game had Halloween
all around it.
So for us, it was a nice update.
It had all to do with what
was happening at the time.
We also updated-- I mean, we
had the new, not Batman movie,
but the new Batman
movie, I don't know
the name-- the "Suicide Squad."
So for us, I mean, there
were characters in the movie
that we could include.
It was around the same
time so we included that.
So Harley Quinn was there.
So I mean, we also
looked at what was
happening in a stronger angle.
And for us, this
matched perfectly
with what was happening outside.
And for us, this also
showed the results.
Number six, maintain and
nurture your fan base.
I mean, again, this is
something that it's really,
I can say on our end,
it's like huge work,
but you need to constantly
look at what people
are saying about your app.
You have to answer to
comments on the store.
This morning, Google was
also saying the benefits
that you have whenever
you're addressing to comments
and the reviews.
So people are reviewing your
app and you're constantly
checking it.
And you're being sure that,
OK, someone reported a bug,
I'm being sure
that I will fix it.
I will see if it's true or not.
And you can also answer-- and
you should always answer--
the users so you get feedback.
And that should drive
the ratings of your store
higher up.
And this will get you
better results in the end.
So social media-- again,
it's not something
that we push for it, but
social media, sometimes we
search for it.
So even though we
are not like 100%
giving away our stuff
on social media,
we are reading
through social media
to see what are the trends,
what people are saying.
We are looking at PR.
We are looking at what the
media is saying about our game.
We are looking at YouTubers.
Sometimes we get insights
from YouTubers that are just
commenting on our game.
And they are commenting
like, hey, I like these,
I don't like this.
We are reading
through the comments
and seeing the comments and
what people are saying about it.
So all of this empowers our
understanding of our fans
and what they want.
And this also empowers us.
Sometimes with trends and stuff
that sometimes we didn't even
imagine, but someone
might say, hey, I really
love this game, "Imagine,"
version 2, where
you added this, this, and that.
So we can read some trends and
we can translate these trends
later on to our
different games or just
for us to evolve on something.
So again, this is really,
really, really important.
And I cannot stress the
importance of this slide.
And here's an example.
This was actually not an
app, but this was more
to promote "Powerpuff Girls."
We were relaunching the
"Powerpuff Girls" this year.
And it was important
for us to talk about it.
And I mean, we have a huge
fan base that are older people
because "Powerpuff Girls"
is more than 20 years.
So we wanted to
communicate with an older
audience that loved the show.
We wanted to let them know
hey, "Powerpuff Girls" is back.
So what we produced-- and
we had an app, a paid app,
for the "Powerpuff Girls."
And what we did with this
was a web application
that you could access
through your mobile phone
or through the site.
And it was a way to spread
out the word like, hey,
the "Powerpuff Girls" are back.
They have a new look.
So it was more of
a marketing tool.
But for us it was
really impressive.
When we launched this, we didn't
expect the success that it was.
I mean, a lot of PR over this.
We did have enabled
social media sharing.
It was not the app.
It was something
outside the app,
but for us it was
good either way.
So in this, you had
like, if you're over 13,
you could publish
this on Facebook.
If you are younger
than 13, you could
save to your desktop
or something,
save to your computer.
So again, this is stuff that
kids can manage to-- OK,
say I'm older, but
either way, it's
a way that parents feel safe.
Oh, no, Cartoon is
looking at my kids.
They are not
publishing something
that I don't want to see.
And again, this was everywhere.
Everyone started
publishing the avatars.
They changed on Facebook.
It was everywhere.
So for us, this
was an initiative
that helped placing
the "Powerpuff Girls"
brand in the consumer's mind.
And for us, this was really
important at the time.
Analytics-- key.
Again, once you release your
game, take a look at analytics.
Take a look at what is
happening on your game.
So let's say you have a
long tutorial on the game
and suddenly you see
analytics-- people are just
dropping your game from
the five seconds to start.
You're having a lot of
give ups on your game.
So maybe you should
look at it and change.
Maybe kids don't
want a tutorial.
Maybe it can be skippable.
Sometimes we realize,
you place a skip button,
and it's not big enough.
Sometimes it's small.
People don't understand.
So even-- and this
is not for kids only,
but you should consider
adults as well.
Sometimes we are like,
come on, this is so clear.
How come the user is
not understanding it?
But believe me, the
users don't understand
it a lot of the times.
So try to change your app.
And that goes with
what I said before,
which is actually
iteration, which is actually
changing your app,
learning with your app,
and looking at the numbers
and see what is happening.
Look, if you change something
and suddenly the numbers
go down, maybe, OK,
that's not a good move.
Maybe we should reevaluate
and change it again.
So this is something
that you need
to measure your app
from every single step.
And just keep looking
at the analytics
and see what is happening.
And see how you can
improve based on hard data
and not based only
on user feedback.
That's something,
but this is going
to empower your user feedback.
So if you see analytics
going bad in some place,
and if you see your users are
complaining in the same place,
OK, so you have two
things to tackle at once.
So this is an important
thing to notice.
Here is about SEO.
So I think I've run
out of time, right?
I tend to speak a lot.
Right?
Yes?
Yes.
I'll just move on fast.
So SEO.
Optimize your app for it.
I mean, make sure
that it's searchable.
Make sure that you're
having the right text on it.
addressing the right words
to make it findable.
I mean, in the end, everyone
is on search engines.
Nine, marketing strategy.
I mean, if you don't have
a marketing strategy,
think on about how
to make partners.
If you don't have money, try
to partner up with other people
and just understand how you
can empower your marketing.
We do a lot of marketing.
We are constantly
looking at what
other people are doing, how
they are marking their apps.
And we are constantly
learning from that as well
and we apply that to our apps.
Here is an example that,
for us as a TV channel
and as a big media
company, we are
lucky that we have the channels
and we can promote everything
that we do on a TV channel.
And as being number
one around the region,
this really helps us to push
everything that we produce.
So this really helps us.
Again, number 10, and
this is it, I'm done.
Public relations.
I mean, think on
public relations
as something more expanded.
So not only look
for, I would say,
the traditional one, like
talking with the press,
but think that public
relations, right now,
is way bigger than that.
I mean, think on YouTube.
YouTube, right now, you
have so many YouTubers that
are creating just app reviews.
So they are sometimes
as big or even bigger
than a traditional media press.
So you should go to these
guys and talk with them
and try to start a
relationship with them somehow.
Give them your app so they
can test it-- if they like it
or not, or something like that.
So this is something that might
be really good for your app.
And that's it.
I'm sorry.
I ran out of time.
Thank you very much.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you.